5 17 on your Friday morning if you
thought maybe you heard music coming
from all over town a couple of weeks ago
maybe you did
well there's no need to Jazz it up over
a three-day period at the beginning of
the month the Nevada music educators
Association hosted upwards of a thousand
middle and high school students from 45
middle schools and 53 high schools for
this year's All-State Festival
from workshops and rehearsals with
leaders in their fields at various
schools the bigger groups needed bigger
rooms including UNLV Central Church in
Henderson and the Las Vegas Academy
from multiple Mariachis to gobs of
guitars the bands orchestras and choirs
sang and played music's praises to
appreciative audiences
plenty of studies showing the academic
benefits of Music in the lives of our
young people and the music educators
group plan here to expand next year's
Allstate to include elementary students
we always want to know what's cool at
school if you got something let us know
cool at school on the community tab of
our website or just email cool at school
at 8newsnow.com wanted to give a shout
out to the leadership team there at the
Nevada music educators Association for
putting all of that stuff together oh
yeah because it was a logistical
nightmare I can't imagine and they did
it so many students so many musicians
and so many locations around town to
make it all happen but it was awesome
and uh Amy Sims is the incoming
president for next year over at Ko
Knutson so Amy congratulations yeah you
know I I remember that so well because I
played in performance Orchestra all
through school and you know it's a lot
of time practice and logistically
parents got to get your kids where they
need to go
it's a a big shout out to the kids the
teachers the parents that really get all
that going and make it happen and it's
something that sticks with you forever